joining me now is Kristen Slough she's
the wife of Paul Slough one of the
blackboard contractors who you just
heard about he was convicted for killing
unarmed Iraqi citizens when responding
to that car bomb attack in 2007 and in
as a u.s. is in a US federal prison as
we speak Kristen thank you for being
here tonight now prosecutors in Manning
the media say this is a clear-cut case
of American contractors stepping over
the line that they are still you know
subject to US law and law in foreign
countries and they have to suffer the
consequences and you say well I say that
the law applies to everyone but
unfortunately what did not happen was
the law here this investigation was
performed by an Iraqi police colonel
that was tied to terrorist organizations
the FBI didn't show up until three weeks
later they accepted this investigation
that was done carte blanche and
presented it to a civilian jury in
Washington DC seven years later they put
lipstick on a pig and presented it as
fact and that is a real problem for us
as a matter of fact the case was
dismissed after the first three years
for reckless rights violations and only
came back after political pressure from
the Iraqi government now you just heard
some military leaders McRaven so forth
saying basically this would be a
terrible precedent for the president to
do this what do you say well I don't
think that the president should create
wholesale pardon process for people who
are accused of crime just because
they're you know service members but I
do think he has not only the right but
the responsibility to look at things
like that when we've seen so much
precedence of prior administrations
using the DOJ and the FBI as you know a
hit job against their enemies or people
that serve their political agenda your
husband had an incredible military
career he did Army Commendation medals
good conduct medals obviously a lot of
Serban ribs service ribbons Air Force
Reserve metal combat infantry he had a
pretty pretty incredible career so yeah
the the thought would be he just snapped
yeah that's the most ridiculous thing
I've ever heard you aren't one person
every single day of your life
in a totally different person on one day
of your life you know ever before and
ever since the most serious violation
he's had as traffic violations he's been
in prison for four years and he's used
that time to better himself to read to
lead people to Christ he has a purpose
in this we believe he has a purpose in
being in the place where he is now but
we want that season to be over we want
you know God to restore him to our
family you know my husband uses these
little origami books to make little
animals out of dollar bills for my
daughter every week when we drive to go
visit him so we believe in God we
believe there's a purpose to all of this
and we believe he uses all things for
good but we're ready in her part of
heart believe he did not fire on unarmed
Iraqi civilians my 15 year anniversary
with this man is tomorrow and I can tell
you with every amount of confidence from
day one until day now that he did not
hurt people intentionally that were not
a threat to him so they were taking
incoming fire and had to respond
absolutely why did the FBI not show up
for three weeks later well kind of an
anti Blackwater
Erick prints kind of deal because there
was a there was a big push against
Blackwater at that period of time Iraq
in 2006 for like a week and I was
hearing a Blackwater black ler and I was
like okay so there was a lot of anti
Blackwater sentiment building is
absolutely so you know the crazy thing
about this is my husband gets back from
this event and we're kind of talking
about it later and he said you know the
weird thing was is the actual event
itself was like a normal day at the
office what wasn't a normal day at the
office
was the response to it and I believe a
lot of people are killed I mean normal
day at the office well unfortunately
that was during the surge in 2011 in
Baghdad in Nazira square all right we
gotta go but hey Buddha just came out
slamming the President on pardons and so
forth we're gonna be following this very
very closely we really appreciate your
joining us and